US President Donald Trump says he's
cancelled a secret meeting with the
Taliban in the United States leaders
were supposed to fly to Camp David on
Saturday night US Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo says talks with the Taliban
are now dead for the time being and the
special envoy is being recalled meetings
between him and the Taliban have been
going on in Qatar for nearly a year it
was the case that when the Taliban tried
to gain negotiating advantage by
conducting terror attacks inside of the
country president forum made the right
decision say that's not gonna work we're
gonna walk away from a deal if others
try to use violence to achieve better
ends in the negotiations not right it's
not appropriate it killed an American
and it made no sense for the Taliban to
be rewarded for that kind of bad
behavior well the Taliban has released a
statement in response saying Americans
will suffer more than anyone else
because of Trump's decision to cancel
the talks while the office of Afghan
President Ashraf Ghani says peace will
only be possible if the Taliban stop
launching attacks and hold direct talks
with the government we expected an
outcome that could lead us to a
ceasefire that could lead us to a direct
negotiation with the Afghan government
and the Taliban
so unfortunately so that's that's we
didn't see our current error a we saw
and we observed that there could be
risks to any process that the Afghan
government is not the main stakeholder
in that and any process that cannot
guarantee a ceasefire a halt to the
violence could be harmful for all of the
achievements that we've gained while
Tony Burley is standing by in Kabul but
first let's go to rob Reynolds in
washington DC Rob how is the news of
this cancellation playing out there well
certainly there was a lot of shock Rob
when President Trump tweeted on Saturday
that there had been this meeting planned
for Camp David Camp David of course is a
very historically significant place and
many wondered whether
the idea of having the Taliban
leadership go to meet with the president
there was appropriate but now that the
meeting is off people are saying that
the president made the right call at
least those within his his own inner
circle as you just heard from Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo he said that the
talks are dead for the time being he
gave no indication as to whether or when
they might restart secretary Pompeo also
warned that things are about to get
worse in his words for the Taliban after
the killing of a US soldier in a car
bomb attack in Kabul on Thursday now
members of the president's own party as
well as members of his inner circle
including the national security adviser
John Bolton had been dubious about the
talks with the Taliban they had been
counseling the president that the
Taliban's word could not be taken at
face value and that the organization
could not be trusted to keep its
promises but the president has made
promises of his own namely that he would
withdraw the remaining 14 thousand US
troops from Afghanistan not to do so or
to not be able to fulfill that pledge
could have political repercussions for
Trump and Trump has used this tactic
before Rob both as a businessman and as
president of walking away from a deal in
the final stages if he felt that he
could get a better position or
strengthened negotiating position by
doing so you will recall that in the
run-up to his first meeting with kim
jonghwan the north korean leader he
abruptly cancelled the talks and then
the talks were back on after a fairly
short time so it would not be surprising
I think for many in Washington to find
out that after a certain period of time
the talks were to resume but that is
completely up to the president Trump Rob
for now thanks very much indeed I want
to go to Tony Berkeley who's with
from Kabul obviously the Afghan
government has essentially been
sidelined for many of the talks that
Rob's been talking about there what's
the reaction been there well in public
they're very supportive of the American
peace process in private they have been
very critical but today they're
welcoming this move by the US president
they've always said that they should be
party to these talks
the Taliban refused to talk directly to
the Afghan government they consider them
puppets of the Americans and
illegitimate and corrupt ironically the
the way this is all played out that the
Taliban said that they were close to an
agreement whereby they were going to
start talking with the Afghan government
on September the 23rd they perhaps have
been the most surprised by this tweet
from Donald Trump because they were
expecting this draft agreement to be a
done deal they said they were talking on
Saturday with mr. Khalilzad the chief US
negotiator and according to a statement
they've released today that they said
that both sides were in total agreement
the agreement was finalized
international regional countries had
been in agreement with this and they
they were very surprised that this has
been stopped at this stage they positive
they tweeted positive statements on
Saturday so this has come as a shock to
them but they also said in their
statement that America as you said
before would suffer more than they would
now that's anyone's guess what that's
going to mean there's two choices facing
the Taliban now do they go away escalate
the conflict or do they come back to the
negotiating table at some point in a
different frame of mind we find a wait
and see which frame of mind that will be
Tony thanks very much indeed let's talk
to David said me he's a senior associate
at the Center for Strategic and
International Studies he's also a former
US Deputy Assistant Secretary of Defense
for Afghanistan Pakistan and Central
Asia he's joining us on skype from Kabul
thank you very much indeed sir for
giving us your time one watching from
the outside would get the sense that
there was we were reaching a significant
moment in these talks
if these talk this secret meeting was
supposed to be held at Camp David do you
think given your diplomatic background
sir that the president
reaction and response has been
proportionate I would say that certainly
from my perspective here in Kabul
talking to Afghans I think they're the
vast majority of people that I speak to
welcome this decision the fact that this
agreement was reached earlier in the
week and then followed by a wave of
attacks on Afghan cities in the north
and the west of the country and then by
a brutal bombing here in Kabul sent the
message to Afghans that the Taliban were
not interested in peace their focus was
on military victory and that the US
agreement was a withdrawal agreement not
a peace agreement so from that
perspective I think there is clearly a
lot of work to be done the Taliban are
claiming that US will suffer but in fact
it's Afghan civilians who are suffering
the most they're the ones who are being
killed every day by the Taliban and in
crossfire between the Taliban and
government forces but by and large I
think most Afghans think this is the
right thing many would love to have seen
peace but they didn't think the
agreement that the u.s. brought was
going to be a peace agreement we heard
our own US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo saying that the deal was
essentially dead for now what does it
take do you think to try to get this
process back on the road again I think
it will take really a mind change a
mindset change on the part of the
Taliban they have to show that they want
peace they are rebuilt they are willing
to stop using violence if they do that
then the talks can resume but right now
again this the very direct bunch of
signals the actions for the Taliban over
the last week have been exactly the
opposite that they're interested in
military victory not in peace and how
that's going to play out inside the
Taliban is a difficult question give us
some context on that sir if you would
how much of a disconnect is there
between the Taliban members who are
going through the negotiation process
and the land are at the leadership and
the Taliban groups on the ground
perhaps outside the influences as well
who perhaps do not want this peace
process to work well I'm not inside the
Taliban so I can't say that with
certainty but it does appear that
there's a fairly large disconnect
between the Taliban negotiators and what
the Taliban commanders were doing this
coordinated assault across northern
Western Afghanistan on on four
provincial capitals was not something
that they did on the spur of the moment
it had to have been carefully planned
carefully thought out a lot of logistics
put in place before these attacks took
place and it doesn't appear that the
existence of this agreement in Doha made
any difference to the military
commanders here so I think it's very
much an open question as to whether the
column on speak with one voice thank you
very much indeed for giving us your
analysis David said knee we appreciate
it thank you